I do want to make a quick comment on the
relationship between these two things
and give you a really critical
counterexample to well you'll see what I
mean okay so here's the here's the
important idea you need to get right a
converse a converse is a seabream
but in geometry and with regard to like
the properties or you know shapes or
particular kind of curve or song like
that the converse of the theorem is uh
you know saying that the reverse or
something the opposite statement like
the statement view from the other side
is true so the most famous converse that
we use and work with is this guy if I
tell you this is a right angle triangle
okay and then we label the sides in such
in such a way then the statement that
would come to mind immediately for you
guys is a squared plus B squared equals
C squared right so this is Pythagoras
theorem that the sum of the squares of
the two shorter sides that are writing
the triangle is equal to the square of
the hypotenuse in a right angle triangle
so that's fine now the converse is to
view this the other way around
rather than to start with a right angle
triangle and some sides and then
conclude this it's to go rather than
this way which is Pythagoras it's to go
in the opposite direction and to say if
you have a triangle and you happen to
know that its sides relating this way
like you measure them out and then you
square these guys you Adam you square
this guy and you end up with the same
result on the basis of saying this you
can therefore conclude what was the
premise from Pythagoras's theorem namely
that there is in fact a wedding
so to go from this relationship in
science to a right angle is is not
Pythagoras theorem
it's the converse of Pythagoras theorem
okay now this is exactly the way that
properties and tests relate to each
other okay so easy temple arm draw for
me a rectangle
now a rectangle one of that like the
most obvious statement jumps out to me
when I see rectangle is well there are
many special things about it it's one of
the most special quadrilaterals out
there but for me the obvious thing is
okay I see four right angles like when I
if I see a bunch of shapes the theme
that immediately my mind my eye goes to
is okay I see the angles BAM it's a
rectangle okay so it is a property it's
a property of a rectangle right to say a
rectangle has four right angles okay we
know this should be true but to think of
this in the opposite direction so think
of the converse makes us no longer a
property but what we call a test that
you'll see why the converse of this is
to say this in Reverse okay if rather
than saying going in this direction
you know this therefore you can deduce
this or you can stand it I want to go in
the opposite direction so if I have four
right angles right a quadrilateral
with four right angles if you know this
to be true then you can also say the
opposite thing which is that it must be
quadrant must be a rectangle there's no
choice it can't possibly be anything
else I mean you could say oh it's going
to be a square but all squares are types
of rec teams they are rectangles where
the two opposite science
pairs are equal to each other BAM is
your square okay so it's important that
you understand that properties and tests
our applications of this right and so
man it's important to understand the
relationship between these because
understand these allows you to test for
these